merhaba Bu dersimizde İngilizcedeki
sıfatları ve sıfatlarla cümle kurmayı
öğreneceğiz sıfat dediğimiz kelimeler
insanları ve cisimleri niteleyen uzun
kısa güzel çirkin gibi kelimeler Hatta
aslına bakarsanız sayılar ve renkler
bile birer sıfat işte size kısa bir
liste tüm sıfat cümlelerinin ortak
özelliği sıfattan önce B fiilinin
hallerinden birinin gelmesi Biz şu ana
kadarki videolarda be fiilinin hallerini
is are ımcı fiilleri olarak öğrendik
diğer hallerini öğrenmek için henüz
biraz erken Bu yüzden sıfat Cümlelerini
kurarken yine is are kullanacağız
şimdi çok basit bir sıfat cümlesiyle
başlayalım sind güzeldir Bu olumlu bir
cümle olduğu için özne Art B fiili yani
emizar Art sıfat yapısını kullanıyoruz
sind is Beautiful Bu kadar basit olumsuz
cümle kurarken yardımcı fiilin yanına
not getiriyoruz soru cümlesinde ise yine
Yardımcı fiil ile öznenin yerini
değiştiriyoruz Cindy güzel bir kızdır
cümlesinde olduğu gibi sayı sıfatının da
işin içine girdiği durumlarda sayı
sıfatını diğer tüm sıfatlardan önce
yazıyoruz Yani şöyle Cindy is a
beautiful girl sakın Türkçedeki gibi
düşünüp Cindy is Beautiful a girl
Yapmayın bu hata çok sık yapıldığı için
özellikle vurgulayarak tekrar söylüyorum
cümleniz de 10 tane bile sıfat olsa bu
sıfatların en başına sayı sıfatını
yazıyor
sıfatlarla cümle kurmak basit Biz şimdi
işin biraz detaylarına bakalım Mesela
sind ne kadar güzel diye sormaya
çalışalım bunun nasıl yapılacağını 4
dersimizde öğrenmiştik how soru
kelimesine kullanıyoruz ama nasıl
demeyin nasıl olduğunu ben de biliyorum
havın yanına sıfat geldiğinde nasıl
anlamını yitirip ne kadar anlamını
kazanıyordu inanmazsanız 4 dersimize
dönüp bakalım soru kelimesinin yan
geldiğinde ise İşler değişir ve bu sefer
ne kadar anlamı Katar o zaman cümlemiz
şu şekilde oluyor
Beautiful kelimesini fiziksel
güzellikten bahsederken kullanıyoruz
mesela toplantı güzeldi yemek güzeldi
falan derken tercih etmiyoruz bu tür
durumlarda kullanabileceğimiz hoş bir
kelimemiz var nice bea kullanıldığı
hemen her durumda kullanabilirsiniz
Ayrıca bir de c diye bir sıfatım var ki
bunu da yine hoş Şirin gibi
kullanabiliyoruz şimdi şu cümleyi Siz
kurmaya çalışın benim babam
uzundur My is long diyenlerin babasının
şu şekilde olduğunu tahmin
ediyorum dikey uzunluktan bahsederken
tercih etmemiz gereken sıfat tall yani
My father is
demeliyiz hocam My is long diye go'
tırak içinde arattım 137 tane sonuç
çıktı diyenlere Sorum şu şekilde
sonra ne yazıyordu Muhtemelen Gun veya
Dead yazıyordur My father is long Gun ya
da My father is long Dead bu tür bir
cümlede long sıfatı babasını değil
babasının Ne kadar süredir hayatta
olmadığını niteliyor yani çevirisi şöyle
Babam uzun süredir hayatta değil Yine en
çok karıştırılan sıfatlardan Diğer ikisi
de small ve
Little small fiziksel olarak küçük
olmayı Little ise yaşça küçük olmayı
belirtirken kullanıyor
small for his Age cümlesi o yaşına göre
küçük demek yani yaşıtlarından daha kısa
boylu olabilir He is a little boy
cümlesi ise o küçük bir çocuk anlamına
geliyor ve bu küçüklüğün yaşça olduğunu
anlıyoruz sıfatları pekiştiren sıfatlar
da var Bunlar Türkçede de kullandığımız
çok aşırı oldukça gibi
kelimeler İngilizcede kullandığımız
başlıca Pekiştirme sıfatları şunlar
öğrencilerin yaptığı tipik bir hata
sıfatları niteleyen bu pekiştirme
sıfatlarını nesneleri nitelerken de
kullanmaya çalışmak mesela bahçede çok
ağaç var gibi bir cümle şu şekilde
kurulmamalı
are in Garden bu tür cümlelerde
nesneleri nitelerken kullanabileceğiniz
çok anlamına gelen sıfatlardan bazıları
şunlar lots of demar many
Much O zaman birini seçelim ve cümlemizi
kuralım there are a lot of trees in The
Garden şimdi ölçü bildiren sıfatlara göz
atalım bu sıfatlardan bazıları şunlar
High long tall White Old
Deep bu sıfatlarla o uzun o kısa gibi
cümleler
kurabilirsiniz bunlarla yetinmeyip o şu
kadar uzun o bu kadar kısa demek
isterseniz iş değişiyor ve sıfat ölçü
biriminden sonra geliyor Everest 8848
metre yüksekliğindedir cümlesini
kurarken şu şekilde yapıyoruz Everest is
8848 veya Nil 6853 km uzunluğundadır
diyelim the n
is videomuzda sorup söylemeyi öğrenirken
cümleleri neden years old ifadesiyle
bitirdiğimiz de sanırım şimdi
anlamışsınızdır
[Alkış]
bir cümlede birden fazla sıfat
kullanacaksanız izlemeniz gereken şu
şekilde bir sıralama var sayı fikir
boyut şekil yaş renk köken yapıldığı
madde
amaç Tabii bu kadar sıfatı Tek bir
cümlede kullanmanız zor Ama birden fazla
sıfat kullanacaksanız ve hangisini
hangisinden önce getireceğim diyorsanız
bu dizilimi
kullanabilirsiniz biz yine en kötü
senaryoyu düşünerek hepsini tek bir
cümlede kullanmaya çalışalım o güzel
Büyük yuvarlak antik kahverengi bir
ahşap İngiliz
sehpası it is a beautiful Big round
antique Brown English wooden coffee
table gördüğünüz gibi tüm sıfatların
arasına virgül koyuyoruz Ancak son
sıfatlı nesnenin arasına Türkçede olduğu
gibi virgül koymuyoruz
Evet bu konuyla ilgili olarak tüm
Söyleyeceklerim Bunlar şimdi bu derste
öğrendiklerimizin kullanıldığı film
alıntılarım gelecek ardından da çeviri
ile öğren kitabımdan konuyla ilgili
alıştırmalar çözeceğiz kitabı satın
almak veya bu dersin yazılı şeklini PDF
dosyası olarak indirmek için konu
anlatımı ncom siteme
gidebilirsiniz kendi Elinizde bir özel
ders öğretmeni arıyorsanız da
özelderscom sitesine bakabilirsiniz
şimdi film alıntılarım gelsin
[Müzik]
You Are Beautiful You are so
Beautiful because it's
[Müzik]
Beautiful it's
Beautiful She was beautiful
to me She was
Perfect isn't He
beautiful the most beautiful Thing i've
Ever
Say yes You're Beautiful fearful
Fragile That's such A beautiful
[Müzik]
Dancer Beautiful
actually i Said beautiful
şimdi öğrendiğimiz Bu konuyla ilgili
alıştırmalar çözeceğiz bunun için
çeviriyle öğren kullanacağız sizden
Türkçe cümleleri İngilizceye çevirmeniz
isteyeceğim Biraz sonra cümleleri
ekranda gördüğünüz zaman videoyu
durdurun ve kendinize 5 dakika kadar
süre tanıyın Hazırsanız başlayalım
[Müzik]
Ora çok hızlı cümlesindeki çok
pekiştirme sıfatı bir sıfatı nitelediği
için very really so gibi sıfatlar
kullanabiliriz that Car is very
Fast New York'ta çok gökdelen var
cümlesinde buradaki çok sıfatı gökdeleni
yani Bir nesneyi nitelediği için biraz
önce saydığım sıfatları kullanamıyoruz
burada Mesela a lot of tercih edebiliriz
there are a lot of skyscrapers in New
York Onlar ne kadar zengin cümlesinde ne
kadar anlamını how la veriyorduk ve
yanına direkt sıfatı getiriyorduk how
Rich are
they Pasifik Okyanusu 11.000 metre
derinliğindedir cümlesinde bir ölçü
belirtildiği için burada hemen ölçü
biriminden sonra sıfatımı getireceğiz
The Pacific Ocean is 11000 met Deep o
eski küçük bir İtalyan evi cümlesinde
sıfatların sıralamasını derste
anlattığım dizilime göre yapmamız
gerekiyor it is a small Old italian
House önce boyut ardından yaş daha sonra
da köken
getirdim bu tür alıştırmalar hoşunuza
gittiyse devamını çeviriyle öğren
kitabımda bulabilirsiniz tanıtım ve sa
sayfasına gitmek için sağ üst köşedeki i
harfine tıkl bilirsiniz Ayrıca bu kanala
ekleyeceğim yeni videolardan haberdar
olmak için sol üst köşeye tıklayarak
kanalıma abone olabilirsiniz izlediğiniz
için teşekkür ederim Bir sonraki videoda
görüşmek üzere hoşça
[Müzik]
kalın i